We were kind of thrust in the limelight a year and a half ago or so.
We were taking care of this little eight-year-old girl with megaloblastoma, that's a brain cancer.
And the parents just questioned the use of continued chemotherapy after she didn't have surgery to remove it.
Then they came to me and said, we don't want to do any chemo.
And I said, well, we're going to do our whole program, started on our whole program.
And then the parents said, well, I don't know if we want to do any more chemo
that oncologists said you need to do all this other chemo, and we need to do full spine, full brain radiation.
And the parents just said, I don't know if we want to do this.
When they got home, there was a sheriff at the door with child protective agency.
People don't realize it, but your children are not your children in the United States.
There is not a state in the United States that can't do the exact same thing to you.
Once you're in the system, if you don't follow this quote-unquote standard protocol,
you are in hot water, you are declared an unfit parent.
They threaten that not only will that child be taken away and put it a foster care
and be forced to do the chemo radiation without you present, but also her older sister will be taken away
because you're going to be declared unfit parents.
So the mother ended up going, do the chemo, do the radiation, though we pushed her down to Chicago
where they had a unit that used a little bit less radiation.
We negotiated that, but our local news station, Carol Levin, came up and did a little bit on her,
and interviewed me because I was helping her, and then the state medical board came down right after.
So they don't like me, so they still don't like me.
We still get letters from that.